un père nastic plus mastoc berner le
plus pervers
je vous offre quelque chose avait lancé
farid en voyant débarquer l'internât
stick est l'un des revers dans le petit
bistrot de la goutte d'or de long pour
les impairs qu'ils avaient répondu en
choeur talent d'arqués conquis la des
aviateurs le chauffeur de choper lia
l'as du sac de boulbon d'abord on n'en
jetez plus chauvel ça vient d'où sa
chope et c'est important
il semblerait du globe si on est là
c'est que c'est important c'est pas ton
bras l'enchanteur boulistes allez c'est
pas pour la preuve coloré non puisque je
vous dis c'est bouddhistes tibétains
c'est quoi un petit matin s'il est un
véritable petit je te dis chapelle
tibétains je suis boulistes bouddhiste
ça va être long se distinguer et non pas
que farid ben amar ben baba fareed
aminches opel surnom ma copine bébé ou
sa copine le daily mail on était copains
il s'appelle comment enfin face à
mourenx farman la nationalité française
soit un passeport français
moi j'ai un peu sport france puis quand
même temps puis un certain temps puis un
certain temps ça fait quoi un certain
temps ça veut dire ton achat témoin
français
allez vite en 28 ans de donner sens
exact que 12 56 ton père faisait quoi
mon père gilles peu connues est amer
alimente aussi
mais même quand j'étais jeune et trop
les lusignois dans les sons profession
l'originalité viré non parce que tu vas
entretient donc j'entretiens poste mon
beau père il travaille en usine aussi
non lorsqu'ils seront quel genre de
restaurants resteront klaus on mange
bien et c'est chez les filles c'est cher
et il fait que ce à quoi la très star
en effet que ça il pas un peu diplomate
opus il a été à quel pays nous le dit à
quel point il demande à l'algérie
c'est pas compliqué tu vois on continue
à rire et en politique tu dis juste à
gauche à droite tu dis pas de nom c'est
drôle salle voisine à gauche ou à droite
vidéo bon ben voilà c'est pour ne pas
qu'on les tire je comprends que tu es
vite et un peu oui c'est ça c'est bien
la marge sur le pen qui vaudrait pour
qu'ici avec eux deux si les taux de oui
je voterai pas c'était obligé sinon tu
ta famille par exemple
devinez quel choix en allant tu ta
famille prédilection le paint été
choisie choisi marché quand même un bon
s'arrêter
ils ont tous du cloud mais pas le beurre
j'ai pas dit ça
ah ben oui quoi j'ai dit que le mot
beurre le mouvement beur cinq ans que ça
commence à me casser les pieds
je préfère qu'on dise arabe kabyle enfin
désigner les gens parlent en ont peur
j'aime pas ça a coûté plusieurs actifs
que j'aime pas là c'est parce qu'il dise
ça c'est l'heure ces lampes c'est leur
opinion mais jeune paul mobbers cyrus on
revendique en disant je suis embauché un
petit beurre et tout ça moi j'aime
j'aime pas ça va mais toi tu me racontes
appelle un petit quoi écrire alors je
suis parisien alors tu fais rien toi
dont souffre une pression on jamais sur
la jante alu une fois dans sa vie sans
jamais goûter comme ça lui a coûté un
siège et bien d'autres tout le monde a
fait ça m'a défoncé on essaie de faire
rigoler ça te fait mal à la tête ça te
fait quoi
on voulait vu ça me faisait rigoler ma
constament stress a couché avec qui pour
réussir
certainement pas
couche avec un statut vient d'ôter
sardou j'ai fait manoeuvre dans les
usines emballeurs emballer des paquets
des trucs comme ça
picamoles adresse paquet et puis après
qu'est ce t'as fait d'autres j'ai fait
j'ai servi aux instants des petits
boulots quand même fait mon ami un peu
s'accroupit dans le frigo et pas
d'autres c'est tout ça suffit c'est déjà
pas mal non
t'as fait ça quand même temps c'est pas
combien de temps je les fasse sur
plusieurs années un bond de 3 ans quand
j'étais dans le groupe quoi parce que on
gagne notre vie avec ce que vous avez
envie j'ai fait de la rue aussi j'ai
fait la manche dans la rue ah ouais tu
faisais quoi le silence alors que je
faisais les bêtises qui savent apporter
quelques sous cette année tu as gagné
combien ça dépend c'est le film si je
suis qui s'envolent importante parce que
ça dépend des jours de tournage en
grande partie fine c'est ça tu vois
c'est combien soyons clairs pour sac de
nous deux cent cinquante mille francs
250000 combien de jours de tournage de
présence un peu plus de 30 jours de
tournage c'est pas mal payés qu'on est a
déclaré d'impôt s'ils sont me feront cet
effet deux compagnons pas je dépense
partenariat tanneur cie je donne de
l'argent macro mieux attaquer les
banlieues là bas c'est pour le 5000 par
mois comme ça ne paye pas moi tu
dépenses donc je pense pas simple a
gagné 60 dans l'année et à tous les
pensées ce que ça vous dépensez moins
c'est un petit coup à passer à la bande
maintenant tu vas nous expliquer qu'il
ya un thé à miss et qui a que ça à
[ __ ] menaces coups balasko un jeu
puisque pour tous les noms comme ça la
gênait lips et pas dans d'autres lycées
paul nom anthony faut que je réfléchisse
à terme est de faire réfléchir nos 1 on
était à gauche et on va le faire
réfléchir elle
antoine farry en foire alors j'ai trouvé
ta langue à mener sont alors les amis
célèbres
allons-y ben au moins d'accord parfumera
c'est ça non jura l'acteur jack leconte
téléphone alors il nous faut simplement
comme ça vient lui john arnone été
commis par des gens un peu plus normaux
plus âgés plus respectés et respectables
tu vas jean collin le président de ma
grand mère madame mazodier 16 go et la
première fois c'était qui la première
fille c'était qui c'est
c'était à gisors dans une boîte à gisors
ça plaira une première et il revient à
violer j'étais tout seul c'était mon
premier baiser tu m'as bien à tous à
damas encore mise sous pavillon n'a même
pas fait l'amour c'était simplement un
baiser c'était mon premier baiser la
première fois que tu as fait trois ans
renouvelables la première fois que tu as
fait l'amour cet écran je me souviens
plus à peu près j'ai pu hisser +18 chez
pause sous ce qui s'appelait tous cas
montrant généreux étrangères s'étaient
tous cas c'est tout ranger c'est bien ce
qu'il dit des sorties et combien de
filles dans ta vie je suis beau jeu par
nature neige et le maire de près de 10
et 30 plutôt 50 plutôt sans chichis
sorti un soir où le choix c'est ça que
je te demande si ça va plus la masse ont
alors deux hommes en asie dans cette
votation suisse ont pas droit
je suis son il s'amuse on dit pas
laquelle je ne céderai pas sentir avec
ça plutôt calme pour toi tu te calmes
enfin becker faire l'amour ou on est
patriote ou est ce que tu préfères faire
l'amour dans un lit et par nous ta
fiancée maintenant qui s'est ému tueuse
est les maximonstres un débat doit on
est de la rentrée ou votre mac y laissa
oui tu vas rencontrer ou je te demandes
ce mince je te demande quand est-ce que
tu l'a rencontré et où je ne veux pas le
savoir c'est ma vie privée ça et c'est
ça qui nous intéresse mon pote justement
c'est ta vie privée nous vraiment une
bande d'enfoirés on les connaît on se
rend à valangin a reconnu le jura la
campagne la bonne compagnie c'est bien
aller après c'est pas une campagne c'est
en vacances là bas vous piller à la
pluie elle vit avec toi toi vit avec
moins de 2000 à 2006 à l'âge de 19 ans
au lendemain des tentures toujours
s'accrocher pour avoir une comme ça toi
way s'est déjà couché avec un mec jamais
et les mecs se demander où par les mecs
parce qu'on tienne callennec la poule
je ne pensais vraiment pas de quoi je
veux dire j'ai rien contre mais c'est
pas mon truc comme la sédition alors
vas-y a déjà eu des relations sexuelles
avec des mecs je me tâte famille la
faille quand même il faut à désinfecter
quand tu étais petit et grand j'étais
petit fils faire violer par un gang
qu'est ce qui t'a fait il n'a pas pu
faire parce que je me suis rendu compte
que c'est un décalage je sais pas si ce
dont j'ai le temps sont bien moi je me
souviens c'est un peu marc savard
souvenirs de films un vrai et vous avez
quel âge j'ai pas de voir 14 15 ans
c'était quelqu'un de ta famille est en
flash et en nourrice c'est un fils est
le fils de la nourrice
c'est à paris donc c'était un compagnon
d'avant et cher dans le loir-et-cher et
chez les pépés qu'est ce que tu préfères
les blanches les noirs les jaunes aux
couleurs ça m'importe peu l'union
qu'elle soit belle la tienne elle est
blanche lentement
ouais je sortirai que noah oui avec une
jaune oui c'est une arabe
oui c'est une française
coût 2 française tech center est couché
avec un mec pour un film non je ne
souhaiterais pas acceptable pour
beaucoup d'argent et mellie tout ça et
des grands réalisateurs nos yeux
j'ai pris une décision je veux pas
montrer mon cul au cinéma ah ben ouais
je trouve que c'est pas nécessaire de
montrer ses autres manger dieu je suis
dit doris est plus fort tu as des
principes
j'ai pas les principes phase i dont je
conduis tout le monde veut non tu es sur
les tournages dans les aventures avec
les pp non non ce n'était jamais arrivé
ce n'est jamais arrivé j'avais pu passer
ça je ne peux jamais plus je suis fidèle
t'as jamais ça y est je me suis appuyé
sans si tu veux ça peut te faire plaisir
mais ça me fait plaisir mais ça me fait
plaisir je te dis tout de suite après
qu'est ce que tu vas faire en sortant
d'ici imagine que tu sers cet après midi
par exemple quand une supposition tuci
angibaud qu'est ce que tu fais la
première chose que j'ai faite du soutien
par exemple j'ai raccroché en bretagne
et essayiste dans les pieds et puis et
puis j'aimerais préparer mon 45 tours
ont également volé c'est quoi ce 45
tours
je vais chanter quoi d'accord pour faire
danser les gens pour les faire bouger un
peu inquiet de langue en français en
français s'appelle comment son corps
secret le titre tu le connais le morceau
jeu de konami je connais pas encore le
titre
c'est ça qui composent j'écris les
paroles c'est un copain qui fait la
musique
donc on peut pas nous de chanter là non
je peux pas voulu chanter
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai pas la musique
étant souviens pas non je n'ai pas ma
tête la galère dans les colonnes du
temps souviens pas tu vas rentrer
beaucoup mais je vous ai dit que je
travaillais dessus et il va sortir quand
ce disque dans quelques mois c'est
précis tout ça s'avère intéressant au
niveau 6 les actes relatifs aux
internautes au niveau cinéma dans un
film des trucs quoi j'ai pas encore
choisi à des projets moi j'ai des
projets jeudi que le projet qui me
tenait à coeur c'est d'aller cracher
dans vos boîtes à lettres comme sur
tille ans et écrase un peu
sinon ça va mal se passer c'est toujours
toujours en liberté s'est lui fait mal à
l'entendre on lui prévu farid chopel
pour prochaine descente de police la
semaine prochaine sur des f et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou